what is a sound suit
a sound suit is this sort of wearable
sculpture
it can be very still
and yet it can be extremely animated
it's a suit of armor
a retaliation vestment
a political statement
it's a shaman
[Applause]
the first sensor came out of frustration
and my sort of concern as a black male
in america feeling
devalued discarded dismissed
i was sitting in the park one day and
i'm just
emotionally struggling with
the rodney king incident and i happen to
look down at the ground and there was
this twig
and i looked at that twig and i thought
it was something discarded
that symbolically
represented how i felt as a black male
the simple twig was the catalyst for my
first sound suit and so then i proceeded
to collect all the twigs in the park
took them back to the studio
started to build the sculpture
and the moment that i put it on the body
it started to move
it then made sound which then led me to
this other
expression
that was focused around protest in order
to be heard you got to speak louder
when i made the first sound suit
i knew by just looking at it that
it would change my life
i could tell that this was
something other
my first exhibition was in 96
and it was
30 sound suits
and they basically sewed that entire
show
within a month
this was like this overnight sensation i
swear to god
[Music]
today i'm able to
work
in this vast
arena working between bronze and wood
and fiber and
[Music]
performance the studio any given time
there's always eight assistants just
prepping and getting materials ready
i'm very particular about how things are
built
it's deliberate every move is
critically decided
it's a sort of collage of elements
coming together
[Applause]
[Music]
we are in the park armory in new york
city we are in the beginning
phases of a performance titled upright
upright is this performance that really
is this sort of rite of passage that is
accompanied by
12 dancers
and a gospel choir from harlem
[Applause]
the part of the process of collaboration
is the most gratifying thing that i do
i like to bring
a project to a city and hire the city to
build the project
there's a lot of work that is gathered
from
narratives and stories within the
communities all of this is all folded
into
the largest sort of project
so that's why i do it
my consciousness being awakened has
allowed me to sort of
find purpose
[Music]
you